Oracle's a very competitive company and
I think there are a lot of competitive
people at Oracle and I enjoy competition
don't simply conform to conventional
ways of thinking translating a good idea
into a great product is unbelievably
hard we've probably spent less money in
marketing than any company our size in
the world we reach a billion dollars in
revenue and we were having serious
management problems all over the place
our goal was to get to 50 employees and
the goal really was not so much to make
a lot of money my sister once said to me
that whenever I got too close to one of
my goals I immediately moved the
goalposts further away so your question
was are we a loser no if you do
everything everyone else does in
business you're gonna lose what do you
think what do you Google runs on I'll
ask you anyway did they run on water
vapor he's an American entrepreneur
businessman and philanthropist he serves
as the executive chairman and chief
technology officer of Oracle as of April
2016 Forbes estimated his net worth to
be fifty point two billion dollars he's
Larry Ellison and here are his top ten
rules for success Oracle is a very
competitive company and I think there
are a lot of competitive people at
Oracle and I enjoy competition I think
life is is kind of a series a series of
acts of discovery and I think we're all
interested in our limits what we can
accomplish in life and discovering our
own limits and we might find that in
sport we might find that in business I
think we're always you know looking to
discover new things and new things about
each other and new things about
ourselves think things out for yourself
come to your own judgments don't simply
conform to conventional ways of thinking
conventional ways of dressing
conventional ways of acting that a lot
of this a lot of things are are based on
fashion even morality at times is based
on fashion
it was once fat you know slavery was
once not because they're not to be
immoral
you know people are you know people are
shocked that the ancient Greeks had
slaves that that we had slavery in this
country as recently as you know 130
hundred forty years ago so there are
more moral value you have to really go
back to first principles and think
things out for yourself whether they're
scientific principles or moral
principles or business ideas or product
ideas you have to think things out of
yourself ideas good idea a lot of good
ideas there a lot of good ideas there
are a lot of good ideas translating a
good idea into a great product is
unbelievably hard there are so many
details people accuse Steve of stealing
you know the Macintosh from Xerox you
know with the alto computer I was at
Xerox PARC so I used the alto a lot
finishing the alto and turning that into
the Macintosh was enormous ly
complicated in you there were so many
things that had to be done that Xerox
had not done there were a few good ideas
in a Xerox machine but Steve would
translate good ideas not always his good
ideas but he would translate good ideas
into finished product unlike anyone in
our industry you'd have to be Henry Ford
didn't invent the car but he made it
cheap and he made it popular and he made
it accessible to the American people
Steve would translate good ideas into
finished brilliant products we've
probably spent less money in marketing
than any company our size in the world
we have a tiny marketing department and
everybody's like why Oracle's you know
all that sales and marketing we are the
largest employer of MIT and Caltech
engineers in the world we are the
largest employer of Stanford and Harvard
and CMU mathematicians in the world we
are overwhelmingly dominated by
engineering at Oracle the idea that we
are a sales and marketing company which
people will sometimes will write about
quite often is ludicrous on the face of
it because all of our customers who buy
Oracle already happened and if you
already have Oracle there's nothing a
salesman can tell you about how
eight it is to make you buy more G
already uses it the Defense Department
always you already use it all of our
customers 98 percent of our sales or
more are to existing Oracle customers if
we don't have the right product people
don't buy more we will before the
acquisition we spend three billion
dollars a year in software engineering
the company is all about engineering
it's the only thing that works suddenly
we'd hit a wall we reach a billion
dollars in revenue and we were having
serious management problems all over the
place and the people who are running a
company at the billion-dollar company
were the same people that run the
company when we were a fifteen million
dollar company one twentieth the size
and I hadn't had a incredible sense of
loyal to this to those people who'd
worked with me to build Oracle and it
was a very painful realization in 1990
that I was going to have to change the
management team that the company had
outgrown the management that people who
are good at running a 50 million dollar
company are not necessarily those are
the same skills it's not they're just
different not one is better or worse
than just entirely different skill set
in running a 50 million dollar company
and then a billion dollar company and
both skill sets are rare and precious
but we needed a different group of
managers and virtually the entire
management team had to be replaced and
that means I had to ask people who I'd
work with for a decade to leave my to
fire people and that was the most
difficult the most the most difficult
thing I had to do and in business asking
them yeah a bunch of people to leave
Oracle our goal was to get we started
with four employees and our goal was to
get to 50 employees and the goal really
was not so much to make a lot of money
I'm I'm on it I wanted to me a lot of
money in those days was I want to own a
house I want to have a nice car and I
wanted to work with interesting people
and do interesting things then I thought
if I could control my own environment
have a small consulting company an
Oracle started out as a software
consulting company we were
for tandem computer if anyone remembers
those guys we work for IBM that we work
for a lot of different tech companies in
Silicon Valley doing contract
programming fixed-price contract
programming and we did pretty well
actually and again the idea was just to
have a small software contract software
company a budget you know we thought
were a hotshot programmers and we
thought I could make a decent living
doing just that
and quite by accident we built a product
my sister once said to me that whenever
I got too close to one of my goals I
immediately moved the goalposts further
away and I think in business you can
always do more hi Ralph Winkler from The
Wall Street Journal I had a question
about your app's business
I guess it's you've built a phenomenal
generates phenomenal cash flows and a
lot of Pete's a lot by locking in
customers to older software and raising
maintenance fees a lot your after year
that's not going to stop you we assume
it means we do not raise maintenance
fees a lot year after year after year
but people but people buy more software
and they pay the same maintenance fees
that they always pay because I guess the
the point I'm Marc Andreessen for
instance famously said that none of the
startups that work with entries in
Horowitz run Oracle and I guess I'm
wondering over time I know I know it
doesn't have to rely on General Electric
and AT&T and Verizon I'm saying if the
duration which is in Reno which to the
end recent horror which companies have
we lost
well anyway anyway is they run it by the
way they run in reaction of Larry run s
isn't going to run Oracle does that end
up causing your business to shrink
dramatically or well again we know our
our business isn't shrinking it's
growing and is growing rapidly and we
and we have all of our applications in
the cloud starting June 6 it took us six
seven years to rewrite all this stuff
for the cloud then our major competitor
our major competitor s AP didn't do that
so if you look at the market in total
you know that we have you have two very
large companies s AP and Oracle and
applications and then a bunch of smaller
senior person workday what about
those guys well it's gonna be very
interesting to me to monitor work day we
compete with work day all that all the
time and we beat work day all the time
so in the cloud our future our Fusion
HCM has been out for a while again these
are much smaller companies but we are
fully in the cloud come June 6 with a
fully integrated suite so I expect you
know Salesforce will continue to grow I
expect we will be bigger around in pure
sass & pure SAS no no hosting nothing
else but yourselves we're around a
billion dollars right now round numbers
about a billion but si P everyone I mean
what are they going to do if we take
share from sa P n ERP Salesforce doesn't
do ERP workday has got very very
primitive thanksgivukkah work words on
workday they don't use a database they
don't use the database they use an
object store so they can't really do
reporting and they use flash as a user
interface so they can't run on all
iPhones or iPads besides that they're
great alright on that so I'm not worried
about workday
I do think Salesforce is built a
franchise over a long period of time and
they're going to be a formidable
competitor in their space I don't think
workday is whenever we have a
head-to-head with workday in the cloud
our our human resources versus their
human resources we almost always win and
that's before we were fully launched so
I'm not worried about them on their
products too immature and they're too
small and frail I'm not s ap and they
made horrible architectural mistakes
horrible no database mark mark uses a
really good database user will in a
sales force use a really good database
you know these Oracle next we used a
really good database amazingly good
database they used Oracle and they use
really good middleware you know what
they use they use Oracle all right
putting into the next patch workday
all right so soon your question was are
we a loser no that's how it's done
I think mostly God the only problem guys
I have trouble with her at the Google
guys really the Larry and Sergey you
have trouble I
Larry specific way where's me I think I
very per se
yeah Larry per se why because he makes
the decisions over there he run he runs
that company no one else runs that
company and they decided let me be very
clear they do when you program when you
write a program for the Android phone
you write it you use the Oracle tool or
Oracle Java tools for everything and at
the very end you press a button and said
convert this to Android format we don't
compete with Google we don't do anything
Google does we do we just think they
took our stuff and you know that was
wrong that's a completely separate issue
but I mean you think they're evil I
think what they did was was absolutely
an you blame Larry Page absent under
percent Larry Page so with what they did
is evil that makes Larry Page evil know
it makes what he did evil which is quite
different and I know his slogan is don't
be evil exactly and and and not I think
he slipped up this one time but the is a
good guy except this one time when he I
this really bothers me I don't I don't
see how he thinks you can just copy
someone else's stuff it really it really
bothers me
you can't conform in business you'd be
very careful the only way if you adhere
to conventional wisdom if you do
everything everyone else does in
business you're gonna lose the only way
to get ahead to really get ahead is to
be different my objection to cloud
computing is the fact that everyone and
this is you know cloud computing is not
only the future of computing Eddy it is
the present and the entire past of
computing is all cloud I mean
salesforce.com has been around for more
than a decade and so is NetSuite in and
that's what's been around longer than
Salesforce and it's people are saying
well that's cloud computing uh you know
Google's now cloud computing everyone's
cloud computing my objection to cloud
computing unless everyone simply looks
around like yeah like I've always been
doing cloud computing
you know it's like yeah like 10 years
ago but cloud computing the terms only
four years old yeah like yeah but you
know like everything is quiet in the
cloud now you know um and I know I
objection is the asserted the absurdity
you don't like that no no I don't like
the idea of what it mean it's this
nonsense I mean the guys they oh it's in
the cloud well what is that then you say
are we dead but yet we're dead if
there's no hardware or software in the
cloud we are so screwed but it's not
water vapor all it is the computer
attached to a network what are you
talking about I mean what do you think
what do you Google run sighs I'll ask
you anyway did they run a water vapor
I mean cloud they have data [ __ ]
databases next queen of operating
systems and memory and micro processors
and the Internet and all of a sudden it
knows none of that it's the cloud what
are you talking about now so yeah these
seeds I love the feces are we only fun
is that cloud Oh yellow oh whoa whoa
microsoft word change internet the cloud
mass change give it back to these
nitwits on Sand Hill Road I thank you so
much for watching I made this video
because Wafi wife inaho asked me to so
if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do I'd also love to know what your
Larry's top ten rules meant the most to
you what changes are you going to make
in your business as a result leave it in
the comments below I'm going to join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon